تتحول الى حسان مسعود اللي طلعنا ايضا على
ابرز التطورات الميدانيه من الجانب
الاوكراني
تطورات عده ازدهار من مختلف المناطق
الاوكرانيه ابتداء من الشمال والشرق وصولا
الى هنا الى الجنوب الاوكراني كل هذه
المناطق تشهد تطورات كانت قد بدات خلال
هذه الليله بهجمه صاروخيه مكثفه على عدد
من المناطق الاوكرانيه من بينها منطقه
بالمسيرات الانتحاريه وكذلك باتجاه
العاصمه الاوكرانيه حيث اسقطت الدفاعات
الجويه معظم الصواريخ التي اطلقت باتجاه
تلك المنطقه الا ان الحدث الابرز كان هنا
في منطقه كريفيري جنوب مقاطعه
هذه المقاطعه التي تقع جنوب شرقيه
اوكرانيا والتي تعرضت فيها هذه المنطقه
لاضرار كبيره نتابع استمرار العمل على
ازاله الانقاض ورفع اثار هذا القصف الشديد
الذي تعرضت له هذه المنطقه وهي المنطقه
التي تعتبر راس الرئيس الاوكراني
ارتفع عدد ضحايا هذه الهجمه بصواريخ مجنحه
من طراز خاء
101 على هذه المنطقه الى احد عشر قتيلا
واكثر من 28
جريحا من بينهم 12 بحال الخطر وذلك في
اكثر من موقع تم استهدافه خلال هذه الليله
بهجمه مكثفه باتجاه هذه المدينه كما عدد
من المناطق كان هناك مسيرات اطلقت فوق
ايضا منطقه زابوروجيا هذه الهجمات تتزامن
مع استمرار المعارك على جبهات القتال
قياده عمليات جنوب شرق اوكرانيا والتي
تسمى منطقه تافريا تتحدث عن استمرار
المعارك على طول هذه الجبهه الممتده من
جنوبي منطقه دونيات باتجاه جنوب مقاطعه
زابولوجيا وهذه ايضا
الجبهه تشهد محاولات للقوات الاوكرانيه
لاختراق الدفاعات الجويه او الدفاعات
الروسيه في تلك
جبهه وتقول انها استعادت سبع بلدات في هذه
المنطقه
هذه البلدات هي من بين عدد من البلدات
التي كانت في المنطقه الرماديه وبعد
المنطقه الرماديه على امتداد هذه الجبهه
جبهه هذه التطورات على الارض في الميدان
هنا فيزا بروجيا او في المنطقه الجنوبيه
او هناك حتى في الشرق عند منطقه بخموت
تتواصل بالتزامن مع هذه الضربات الصاروخيه
وهو ما ربطه وزير الداخليه
الاوكرانيكو عندما تحدث الينا قبل قليل
وقال ان هذه الضربات التي تمتد وتطال
المدن الاوكرانيه من الشمال الى الجنوب هي
بسبب مخاوف روسيه من نجاح الهجوم المضاد
ومحاوله للضغط على القياده الاوكرانيه
وكذلك على السكان نستمع معا لما قاله وزير
الداخليه الاوكرانيه في اجابه على سؤال
للجزيره
من الشمال الى الجنوب لانهم خائفون من
نجاح هجومنا المضاد لا يحتملون صمود شعبنا
لاكثر من سته عشر شهرا في هذه الحرب
واستمراره في المقاومه لذا يريدون ترهيبه
انهم في وضع يائس